hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to in two
minutes
now dragon Age Inquisition is getting a
final piece of DLC to round off the
story
and give some much-needed answers to
questions like why why but in order to
play trespasser no not that trespasser
you'll need a character that has
completed the main inquisition storyline
given that it's been about nine months
since I finished Dragon Age Inquisition
remembering the key points from a sixty
plus hour RPG is gonna be tough going so
here's my refresher guide for Dragon Age
Inquisition featuring all the stuff that
you need to know for the trespasser DLC
spoilers obviously Inquisition in a
nutshell then big green hole appears in
the sky demons come out of the hole
chosen one with glowing green hand forms
a ragtag band does some politics amasses
an army kill some creatures and closes
the hole it's quite straightforward but
there's some key things we need to
remember for trespasser we can see here
that Vivienne at least in this
playthrough is the divine head of
religious organization the Chantry you
chose who became the divine so for you
it might be Liliana or it might be
Cassandra anyway she's joined by
representatives from the regions of
Orlais and Ferelden and it looks like
the inquisition is in some hot water why
well trespasser picks up two years after
the closing of the breach so the
Inquisition a giant army spy network and
political power which was formed to fix
a certain problem he's kind of just
sitting around not doing anything after
fixing said problem so while that
angered the great powers of Thetis it
might not all matter because the qunari
are up in arms again concerned by the
fact that the inquisitors left-hand not
only gives them the power to wander into
the fade off the realm of the demons
it's also playing up and becoming
uncontrollable so the qunari wants to
kill the Inquisitor to cut the tie to
the fade completely therefore protecting
vedas and its inhabitants from darkspawn
but what about those weird mirror of
Erised said things all over the trailer
they're the eluvian an ancient source of
transportation created thousands of
years ago by the elves but most were
destroyed because the elves realize that
their enemies could use the eluvian to
attack them and I'm gonna go out on a
limb here and
it's probably gonna happen in the DLC
and look here it's soulless part-time
companion general disapprove er and
professional betrayer in inquisitions
epilogue flemeth refers to him as dread
wolf another name for the elven god of
betrayal
fen'harel once responsible for tricking
the gods into leaving the world and it's
people's behind
fen'harel lay dormant for hundreds of
years weak from his slumber he gave
corypheus the orb of destruction which
Cerf is then used to open fade rift and
summon a demon army from so soulless has
definitely got some explaining to do on
top of housing an ancient god he kind of
absorbs the essence of another one this
time mythal
from the body of flemeth he also Nix the
shattered fragments of the orb of
destruction after it got destroyed in
your battle with curry feeis I'm sure
he's not gonna try anything right
so trespassin comes out on the 8th of
September and I already have a few
theories about what I think will happen
but I really really hope that we get to
punch solace in the face anyway any
ideas questions comment let me know in
the box below or find me on twitter i'm
alisa james games i'll see you next time